thanks everyone it's really an honor a
pleasure to be here once again also just
in case someone missed before someone is
missing an iPhone so if you are missing
an iPhone then go talk to the tech guys
over there and describe it one hint it's
not pink or yellow so you have to do a
better job I'm Trent it's really a
pleasure to be here today
I will be talking but yet yet a
different topic that I talked about last
year which is yet a different topic than
the year before
two years ago I was talking about
Moore's law and machine learning and and
semiconductors last year I was talking
about ownership on the Internet this
year I'm talking about something you
know some people might think is more
mundane but it's also super cool and I
don't think it's mundane at all and
that's databases
the common thread from this and last
year is blockchains and I'll just get
started so this is probably a very
elementary picture for most of you you
know if you think about what are the
elements of computing there's really
three things
there's processing the storage this
communication and if you were to sort of
drill into that some more and think
about how that translates to modern
application stacks you probably say okay
well storage breaks into two things
you've got the file system and you've
got the database the file system is
organized by hierarchies of directories
and files the database you know the UX
is relateable query ability and under
the hood to the the hierarchy is really
sorry the the file system is really more
partition tolerant whereas the database
aims for consistency sort of in the cap
theorem sense and on the side you know
the communications is just kind of there
and the protocols that connect and
you've applications on top very
straightforward no problem no problem
and how this manifests itself into
modern stacks this is an example of the
cloud stack and at the top level you've
got applications whether they're
web-based or mobile based Facebook
Netflix Google Maps that sort of thing
wonderful down there on different sort
of platforms cloud platforms like AWS or
Azure ER and those platforms hold a few
elements the processing the file system
in the database or databases so in the
Amazon stack you've got ec2 for the
processing for the file system side
you've got things like s3 for buckets
for blobs
Media and so on maybe a Google Drive and
then for databases you've got things
like my sequel for C and other sequel
cell databases or MongoDB and other know
sequel databases so straightforward
straightforward this is all dead obvious
to you guys I'm sure well you know
there's this whole other universe that's
been emerging for about five years now
starting with Bitcoin and Bitcoin the
paper was released in late 2009 the
software came out in early 2010 and very
quickly I got the label of magic
internet money and people had a tough
time putting their finger on what
exactly it was even to this day is that
money is it an asset is it just some you
know weird crypto anarchist dream what
the heck is it and you know different
things have emerged over time you know
the there's been a lot of hype and a lot
of technology developed and one of the
things that's happened is it actually
really sparked a revolution and that
revolution was people realizing that the
ideas of Bitcoin the idea that you could
have scarcity of something electronic
you could actually apply that not to
just the traditional idea of ecash but
to other things as well so you could say
okay what about other digital assets
what about digital art what if I could
own digital art the way that I own
Bitcoin and this is actually where
escribe kind of came from you know my
company started about three years ago
work on it three years ago or what about
diamonds which isn't digital but it's
something that you can still track with
supply chains right we were just having
conversation what about used cars right
if you had a much better trail of the
ownership of the cars on a database that
no one owns or controls that's pretty
powerful so a Bitcoin sparked this
revolution it morphed into the
blockchain Revolution which was I'll get
into that more later but a blockchain is
really just a type of storage mechanism
and more recently we've things seeing
things like some more contracts and most
recently Dow's especially that Dow and
if you guys haven't seen this I
encourage you check it out
it is rate has raised more than 150
million dollars as a crowdfunding and
it's still on barely halfway through its
its fund raise and the creators of the
Dow are here in Berlin so pretty
interesting there's some crazy things
happening it's really rewriting the
internet for computing I'll get more to
that too so
basically Bitcoin sparked this
revolution but Bitcoin itself and all of
the other blockchain technologies
basically have had a problem scale
Bitcoin has a theoretical max of seven
transactions per second and actually
when you start to go past about 1.5
transactions for per second the network
backs up and it takes about 24 hours for
a transaction to go through they call
Bitcoin blockchain bloated yet it only
holds 50 gigabytes I can hold more in my
thumb drive yet people talk about the
idea of Bitcoin and these other networks
as you know these planetary databases
well what do you know of any planetary
databases that are smaller than your
thumb drive not a very good planetary
database if you ask me so that's a
challenge right what about planetary
scale is there some way to reconcile the
dreams of blockchains with scale the
technology that we need to achieve these
dreams and you might ask well you know
is there other places that have
planetary scale and you guys a lot of
you guys come from the big data world so
the obvious answer is yes but Allah
start with an example Netflix Netflix
uses 37% of the bandwidth of the
internet at least in the USA that's
pretty good I'd say that's probably the
planetary scale usage given that you
know the usage of the internet today
that's pretty good
what's into the core of Netflix it's
well big data in particular the
Kassandra databases actually instances
that they're running there and so
Cassandra databases are actually
powering Netflix to serve up this media
and this is an interesting plot here
what it is is the x-axis is the number
of nodes the y-axis is the number of
writes per second and the first thing
you can see is well on the x-axis
they're more there's more than one node
right there's more than one machine
being used to serve up this data it
starts with you know 50 on the Left all
the way up to 350 on the right and with
50 nodes Netflix Cassandra as the
Cassandra instances are running at
200,000 rights per second and as you
increase the number of nodes as they as
they increased going from 50 to 150 and
more it increased the number of Rights
per second increased correspondingly in
a linear fashion and if you think about
it that's actually pretty cool right it
means
well it's linear scaling and it's
actually able to swallow more and more
and more data and the core idea there of
course is that the data itself
no single node is storing all the data
it's actually being charted up so each
node is short storing a subset and then
when the data is getting written each
node only has responsibility to keep
track of a subset of the data but they
have ways of keeping in sync and that's
what the next part is about so how does
this database keep in sync because if I
put some data here and some data there
and some data there how do I know which
data to look at and what about if one
day to you know one node goes down and I
need backups and I need backups of
backups and so on and that's actually
the idea of replication of course right
so within these distribute databases
there's this idea of consensus which is
algorithms or protocols to main
consistency among the databases at the
log level and these algorithms they go
back to actually do this 60s when the
ARPANET was being worked on and so on
and a lot of theory was developed in the
80s and 90s most notably probably the
first major result was in 1982 with
Leslie Lamport and his colleagues at
Microsoft where they came up with a
concept of Byzantine fault tolerant
behavior and a theoretical solution to
it and Byzantine mate basically means
not only keeping things consistent but
also handling when you have malicious
actors people that are agents that are
trying to break the system and so that
came along and you know it was kind of
ignored ignored ignored this was still
the early 80s there wasn't a lot of big
networks and then in 1990 Lamport and
his colleagues came up with this idea
which they called Paxos submitted for
publication it got rejected so they just
let it gather dust it finally got
published eight years later when the
world really kind of realized hey maybe
we should you know publish this again
and it was accepted it was actually a
really horribly written paper but since
then this this paper Paxos has become
very very famous a is really hard to
understand which isn't quite true but
also as an important result for also
consistency among databases and so what
Paxos is is basically a protocol that's
provably correct to maintain consistency
among the different nodes in a database
and you can implement it and that's
where a lot of the implementations of
early-2000s came from things like apache
zookeeper etc were originally based on
paxos turns out that to implement them
there was some deviations from taxes but
the general ideas held true so there's
this idea of consensus it's been around
a long time and it's what powers things
like Cassandra so going back to the
blockchain world right so blockchains
our revolution though they can
revolutionize stuff but scale is really
really an issue so people have been
talking about okay well let's just scale
up the blockchain let's just scale up
the blockchain well a lot of you guys
have done working machine learning have
you ever tried taking some sort of
algorithm your toy algorithm that you
played with say some genetic programming
and said okay great I'm working on ten
variables now all I needed to do is
scale at my genetic programming and make
it work on ten thousand guess what
doesn't fly right it never ever flies
basically as you have probably seen with
the research from Norvig and others as
you actually go to higher and higher
scales the algorithms change and they
tend to get much simpler and much
simpler and much simpler right you have
to keep the same inputs you have to keep
the same outputs you want to maintain
the same behavior but you have to let go
of your pet algorithm right it's really
about the result
so trying to take an existing blockchain
idea and scaling it up well maybe you
look at 10x if you're lucky or you know
50 X if you're really good and that's
actually what kind of everyone has been
doing you know major debates in the Year
2015 over this you know lots of Tears
but that's every what everyone is doing
we we a started asking the question what
if you instead of Big Data five block
chains what if you block unify Big Data
so what if you start with something that
naturally scales and give it
characteristics that block chains have
right so start with that and there's way
more history of research in Big Data
thanks to the database research going
back decades but then the one question
is how do you block TANF I this what
does that mean right so a lot of people
will have big debates about what
blockchain means and fortunately we've
been doing blockchain stuff since before
it was cool it's very uncool for a long
time
and I don't care but cool or not I just
care about what's you know interesting
to me so I'm going to give you some
definitions leading towards app working
definition for blockchain if I and
blockchain so first of all
decentralization
decentralization simply means no single
entity owns the controls and this is
really useful to disambiguate from the
word distributed so distributed means
the resources are shared among more than
one machine whether it's processing
resources storage resources and so on so
there's still you know a lot of
confusion in the community if people use
the word distributed ledger for example
to mean actually decentralize later so
there's a lot of miscommunication but
this is actually a good practical
definition so you can have centralized
distributed databases and that's
actually what we have with you know the
Cassandra implementations that netflix
has etc but we can also have
decentralized databases where no single
entity owns or controls those databases
immutability this is the idea that it's
more tamper resistant than usual nothing
is perfectly immutable right we already
have logging databases we already have
automatic storage to magnetic tape
drives etc and so there's already
degrees of immutability that we have but
there's things that we can do to make it
even harder to remove what was written
before right so we can do things like
hashes of hashes of hashes sort of like
a snail shell getting larger and larger
and larger and this is actually one of
the newer ideas that blockchains bring
although actually even that research
goes back to the early 90s literature
and time stamping so Satoshi didn't
invent very much a lot of people would
claim that he invented everything and he
does a lot of other magical things but
there's really not a lot of magic it's
actually just good engineering with
decades of history so that's
immutability there's another really cool
idea and that is assets and so the
imagine if you have some sort of storage
medium where assets can truly live on
that storage medium now for that to be
the case no single entity can own or
control that medium because otherwise
they would be owning the asset right so
as a prerequisite you really need the
decentralization and also the ability
that those assets couldn't be
arbitrarily deleted you need the
immutability but once you have that then
you can have assets that live on there
you can issue assets you can transfer
assets and so on and you can define an
asset as I own the asset if I have the
private key to that asset which is
essentially the password so I entered
the password I can transfer to my buddy
then he owns the asset he can transfer
and so on and so on and so on so that's
assets and these three characteristics
together
decentralization and we do billion in
assets this is really what people talk
about as the major benefits they get
when they have a blockchain blockchain
as a storage medium as a noun there is a
ver more narrow definition of blockchain
that goes back to the early 90s and
that's literally this chain of hashes
the time stamping literature etc but
that's really pretty narrow and no one
really liked even though you could argue
that that's the real definition no one
really bothers because there's so much
more value so blockchain the known is
you know some sort of storage medium
that has decentralization immutability
and assets then the adjective is simply
the collection of these three sub
adjectives so blockchain the adjective
means decentralized immutable and assets
that's it so that's the working
definition of blockchain then what we
can do is we can say let's give these
attributes to an existing Big Data
database to an existing distributed data
database so this is how you do it this
is how you block unify Big Data first of
all the key key key thing this is about
scale and speed so you have to say let's
retain the the performance of this Big
Data database so you've got some sort of
Paxos derivative whether it's raft or
something else that's solving order you
get out of the way of that you let it
keep solving order you don't need to try
to sort of order on top and what that is
doing is it's actually not naturally
building this log of all the
transactions and once you have that log
all the other information can be kind of
built on top in this hierarchical
fashion so you let the database keep
doing that right it's all about order
and then once you make sure so that's
sort of a constraint as you're doing
this and then you add in these
characteristics decentralization so
obviously with the centralized databases
sorry with with distributed databases
you've got you know ten nodes 50 notes
whatever what do you say okay each of
those nodes you have a piece of control
and collective you all of you guys have
all the control together right but
that's it so and imagine if you say each
node gets one vote simple enough right
and it's actually as simple as that in a
sort of theoretical fashion you call
this a Federation and then you say okay
for any transaction to go through all
the know a majority of nodes have to say
yes or for a and Jack for a transaction
to get rejected
and what you already have to say no and
they just say no to the transaction and
that's it now if you want you can
actually say okay it turns out you can
optimize this and you can say instead of
doing one transaction at a time let's
vote on a thousand at a time and that's
actually faster and you you group these
thousand transactions into a block and
that's where the idea of a blockchain
comes in because you also have the
hashes in the blocks so you have
decentralization the Federation of nodes
you have immutability via simply hashes
on blocks and a few other related ideas
and then for assets it's basically
saying making it really easy to register
an asset making it really easy to
transfer an asset and and then you have
digital signatures on this so the
digital signature is basically only
myself only I can sign this and then I'm
done so really like at the core core
core level it's really these three
things kind of simple conceptually and
of course though in the real world it
takes effort to get there and I'll just
describe a bit more of the architecture
so overall in the system this is what
big chain DB looks like we actually
built on top of an existing distributed
database we actually looked at quite a
few benchmarked quite a few including
MongoDB Cassandra elasticsearch and so
on and you know the first thing we
noticed was there all wildly better
scaling than any blockchain out there
and we knew that not surprising but then
we actually filtered down to one of the
main characteristics and that was how
good is the change feed mechanism how so
a change feed as in instead instead of
having to pull on the nose to see what
happened what happened would happen how
good they are telling you about what's
happening in real time and rethink TB is
really designed for that from the from
the bottom up so so we we chose rethink
DB it's a JSON style document store
built in C++ and in the architecture
here in the very very center you see
there's three rethink DB nodes that's
the arse probably obvious and then
wrapping each of those nodes is a big
chain DB server node and that's what we
see here so there's a big chain DB
server node for each of those and then
there's the client side whether it's
Alice or Bob or whatever and Alice and
Bob they're running some client-side
software to
that's quite straightforward so that's
roughly speaking the the the
architecture one constraint we gave
herself and this was related to letting
the the core database in our case
rethink TB the constraint we said was
don't add any new communication
mechanisms beyond what we think TB had
because it already has its way of
communicating so if I want to node one
to talk to node 2 then it has to be
actually via storage inside rethink TB
itself and what that looked like was the
following two tables so one table for
incoming transactions and another table
for the actual set of information that's
being stored permanently this sort of
blockchain the set of transactions about
who owns what etc etc etc so the
incoming contract transactions coming in
the left and they're immediately
deterministically assigned to a given
node to handle and the grouped into
blocks as they come along and once
there's enough transactions for a given
block for a given node he writes that
block to the to the table on the right
this is all within one reading to be
instance and other nodes are also trying
to write to their and here's a key thing
when you write to the table on the right
so WRI te writing to the table on the
are you guys know what I mean anyway
when you write to it you let the the
raft algorithm the consensus algorithm
everything to be sort out the order we
don't impose an order we let the
underlying consensus algorithm solvent
so basically things get written on the
right they're grouped together and then
once they're written we actually vote
after the fact because we found that
writing was a bottleneck so we write
right right right right
and then after the fact right okay this
whole group of transactions here are
they good yes no yes and each node votes
and then once the majority has said yes
or a majority I said no you know whether
or not that block is good or not so it's
as simple as that it feels very very
simple and that's because as you guys
have probably seen in your own
experiences when you do stuff at scale
it's really the simplest algorithms that
emerge and that's really what you have
to kind of aim for and can you know you
have to be very you have to constrain
yourself to just the simple in the
elegant now obviously there's a lot of
ways to do things that are simple still
right it's still a big design space for
simple but this is what I'm rich here so
we were benchmarking
and the very first thing we did well as
we iterated on this we said okay if we
design the algorithm just right then we
can actually get away with benchmarking
just rethink TB as a first cut because
everything else we're kind of getting
out of the way so we designed the
algorithm where the the rest of the
algorithm got out of the way and we
could focus on just seeing how far can
we think TB scale so in this set of
benchmarks here what we did was we
started with just one node and then we
added a second a third all the way up to
32 nodes and and then we saw how the
throughput the number of writes per
second increased and you can see as it
goes from 1 to 32 nodes the writes per
second goes past 1 1 million basically
and this is actually blocks of 1,000
transactions were and then it so it's
1,000 writes per second times 1,000
transactions per second basically
speaking so what we could and then this
plot can translate into just a simpler
plot which is very much like the
Cassandra platter before so the x axis
is number of nodes the y axis is number
of writes per second and we can see that
we get one more than 1 million writes
per second this way and this is on
rethink DB knowing that one if we have
rethink DB going really really fast than
everything else all the algorithms
around it we've designed them where they
work too and we'll be releasing
benchmarks in that shortly as well so
basically interestingly enough too as we
were working on this we found probably
four or five six bugs and rethink DB and
we worked with the team everything DB to
help resolve those bugs and often they
made a difference of like 2x or 4x to
the speed so this actually improved the
speed of the rethink TB database we
wrote a paper about this in great detail
some people call it a book because it's
about 70 pages but it's really an easy
read and you know and by the way I'm
getting again I can I will get into all
the Python stuff in a bit here but to
kind of summarize a bit here on sort of
what what is it that we built right one
way of thinking about it is trying to
bring together the best of two worlds
the world of big data distributed
databases and the world of blockchains
so what blockchains bring to the table
is this concept of immutability this
concept of decentralized control and
this concept of assets
and then from the big data world it's
things like it's basically scalability
right so throughput low latency high
capacity permissioning system querying
all this sort of thing and so you know
if you're coming from the big data world
and you ask yourself well why would ever
care about using a blockchain or a block
chain database it basically comes down
to is their value and immutability or is
their value in decentralized control or
is their value in assets so for example
if you are a bunch of if you're the
music labels right and you're not very
happy with how Apple is behaving you
know they're taking the 30% cut and yet
you don't have your own way of so
working together with the other music
industry labels what if you actually had
a way to join forces have a database
that you don't control but none of your
competitors can control other but
collectively you own and control that
right
they tried doing this a few years ago
they failed because they couldn't agree
on a technology because it came down to
one of them controlling it block chains
actually allow them to collectively have
a technology that they only control
collectively so that's one example in
general this idea of consortium
databases is actually a pretty powerful
concept and also we kind of view it as
you know back in the day there was
sequel databases relational databases
then Along Came the no sequel databases
which offered scale which offered ideas
of aggregation and so on or the graph
capabilities and this is sort of a new
type of database that's really emerging
this new blue ocean database and it's
really you know a blockchain database
that's immutability centralized assets
to give you a feel of how people use
this ever ledger is one of our users
customers and they're doing this for
diamonds so basically if you go and buy
a diamond from some dude in the street
how do you know it's not a Blood Diamond
how do you know it didn't come from
child-labor right how do you know it
isn't stolen what if there was a
registry for that diamond that was being
managed by all the major certification
houses of the world and the insurance
companies and the mines etc so this is
exactly whatever Ledger was doing and so
it's the diamond supply chain the
diamond industry is about an 80 billion
dollar industry it's been estimated to
have 40% fraud and it's been totally
opaque so that no one was detecting the
fraud we actually worked with every
ledger we swallowed all their diamonds
that they had so far
as well as some eBay data and so we had
almost a million diamonds and we stole
it a month's worth of eBay USA data and
we actually did machine learning
analytics reconciling the data from the
certification houses five certification
houses which would never talk to each
other before we reconciled that with the
eBay USA Today and found 7% fraud rate
that works out to 750 million dollars a
year worth of diamonds this is an
example of the value of blockchain
so basically 750 million dollars the
fraud that was going to criminals now
it's being prevented thanks to ever
ledger and between dB another example is
energy deregulation so RWE biggest
energy provider in Germany they're being
asked and you know the laws in Germany
and Europe are getting deregulated right
so if you have energy provider a some
guy with a solar pet farm another person
with a wind farm how do they sell that
to the grid who's managing do you want
some centralized controller wouldn't it
be cool if there was no centralized
controller and instead every single node
could talk to every other node and there
are some way where markets are more jet
setter so this is actually the the
promise of blockchain technology and
there's a whole bunch of initiatives
around this working on it so we're
working with our w/e as well in general
to help manage the dollar flow in energy
regulation another example is in the
world of health so if I'm a doctor in
London and bayer comes to me or some
other big pharma and says hey what can
I'm gonna fly you to to Hawaii for two
weeks for this awesome conference all
you need to do is buy my drugs for the
next two years or subscribe to my
medical journals for the next two years
and the doctors like well yeah okay and
how do you know when it's legitimate
versus not right so it turns out that
what the UK government did was they
actually created a law called the
Sunshine Act and every time dollars flow
from hospitals in the UK to any of the
big pharma or any of the big scientific
publishers like Spring etc that has to
be transparent perfect use case for
block chains block chains are
transparency engines no one owns or
controls it so we're working with
tension 90 which is a bunch of experts
from the field to basically shine a
light on the flow of dollars among the
the UK medical professionals
the big 20 pharma and the publishing
interesting one final example this is
overall the company I work for is called
a scribe and we started out I talked
with this last year with IP in the
blockchain we still do this right we had
to talk earlier today from from Ryan who
was actually talking about 3d IP and
it's it's very related to this overall
challenge so if I'm an artist I create
some digital art how do i how do I prove
that I'm the owner when I sell it to
someone else how do they know that it's
me and blockchain technology can help
here so a scribe by oh we're moving very
quickly towards towards using big chain
DB as well for that and overall you know
the art industry itself digital plus
physical is a 64 billion dollar industry
obviously the copyright industry itself
overall is you know hundreds of billions
so Python so if you want to try a big
chain DB it's actually not much
different than using other databases
we've gone out of our way
it's not like trying to use event if any
of you have ever tried to use Bitcoin
daemon or if one of those it's like this
nightmare it's just horrible horrible so
we've got another way to make this
really simple so off of big team DB calm
if you scroll down from the top we have
basically some links to just get a very
quick start so the very first thing is
obviously we've open sourced it it's a
GPL it's on github and you know the link
to github you'll see everything there
all of our tickets all that sort of
thing we've also got another way to
document this really well so we're using
read the docs and I'll give an example
I'll drill in on that on a second
basically to get going and playing with
big chain DB and so installing it
we're also within the pi PI repository
so you can just do this in same simple
pip install big chain DB and you're good
to go
so thanks Sylvain we have a few of our
local Python experts in ascribe so this
helped Kip keep things simple that way
so I'm just going to give an example of
the usage of this big chain DB itself is
all written in Python rethink DB is in
C++ so we've got you know C++ at the
very core and then Python and I'm sure a
lot of you guys have this experience you
shouldn't be trying to write things
prematurely optimize in some harder
slower language like C or something
write it in Python and then any to
anywhere you have bottlenecks that's
where you start to optimize will the
algorithms first and then if you really
need you can optimize in some other
language so this is our path as well so
basically in this case once you have
between DB installed you also have to
install rethink DB which is also simple
then you get everything to be going you
run the configuration of big chain DB
you get it going to start so if the big
chain DB daemon is running and each one
of the server nodes would run this we
have actually scripts to deploy clusters
AWS and so on and then in a new terminal
start up new terminal and get python
going there and I'm just going to give
an example of running a client here so
you first of all import big chain and
then you say B equals big chain which is
now you've got this object of the class
big chain and now I'm just going to show
how you can create a digital asset and
transfer it so it's just dead simple
right you first of all you import this
crypto library from the chain DB and
then you generated a key pair which is a
public key and a private key and this is
just an example of how you get a key
pair of course in a real world scenario
you don't have to do that you would have
it from something else you have some
sort of digital asset payload so this is
the you can have a message or you can
have something very detailed if you want
it's all adjacent so it's
straightforward or Python Dix which
translates to jason and then you create
a transaction which is basically saying
from who - who in this case you're
saying I'm creating so I'm doing a
register and then it's passing in the
payload and then in a crucial thing here
you have to sign the transaction and
this is basically saying you sign it
with your private key and this is
basically proving that it was me who
just doing the transaction so when I
write to the to the big chain DB the
world can see that it was me because
they can verify against my public key
and so after the signing then the step
is just simply to write it and writing
it will actually write it to the big
chain DB server-side instances and of
course you can retrieve that just like
any database so
you know what this is it looked sacks
feels like a database right so this is
probably super dull to you guys like duh
of course this is a database but that's
the thing this is also a blockchain it's
a blockchain database right so the whole
point is that block chains can look can
act can feel like databases so here you
you say what does the transaction look
like you retrieve it and it's got a few
fields basically an ID and then the
transaction information and the
transaction information has three main
sub components the conditions which is
sort of like the inputs the data which
is the payload and you can have a lot of
things like metadata like artist name
etc in there and then fulfillments which
is sort of like the outputs and I won't
get into great details here but that's
roughly speaking how it is once you've
got at the asset that digital asset
created you can transfer it so here at
the very top I'm generating a key pair
for some user number two then I'm
creating a transfer transaction and
that's basically between user 1 and user
2 and then of course I have to sign it
and if I'm not the owner of this then
the signing isn't going to be very
helpful of course so I have the the
previous creation obviously I signed
that one
so I sign it and then the final thing is
I write the transaction and that goes
off to the database now if I neglect you
to sign this or if I signed it with the
wrong private key then when it goes to
the database it would get checked by the
database nodes they vote and they say ah
no good right and then we get kicked out
and actually that's when I just
described the not signing is one of a
broader set of conditions what if I
created that asset and I sent it to
Sylvain and then also I sent it you know
two minutes later to Ryan right well
Sylvain will get it but it will complain
when I try to send it to Ryan it'll say
hey you've got a double spend and that's
what I'm showing here as an example
basically I create the transaction I
sent it to well I sent it to a new
person and it of course complains and it
gives me an error message so in starting
to wrap up here this is the second left
side on the Left I talked about the
centralized cloud stack that we have
today right in the case of Amazon we've
got ec2 for processing we
got a file system or file systems like
s3 and all this and then a whole variety
of databases whether they're sequel or
no sequel or whatever and then the
applications running on top on the web
or on mobile now the world is shifting
this is centralized stuff is going to be
around for a while probably quite a long
time
but we're moving towards something
that's much more decentralized as well
so it's sort of this vision of internet
3.0 so you can take baby steps which is
pretty cool so a lot of the value is and
things like registries where you retain
your full stack that's fully centralized
except for the one thing you add one new
database the new database is big chain
DB so you maybe you keep around your my
sequel database in your MongoDB database
but you also are using this other
database this registry that's out there
that you don't own a control that no one
owns or controls but that a set of
people to collectively own and control
and that's what the middle is so it's
it's partly decentralized and that's
actually the stack that escribe has so
you know we've got centralized servers
running Jango on Heroku and we've got
you know we're using s3 so the
application itself the ascribe web app
is partly decentralized but what we're
moving towards is this world where there
are our applications out there that are
fully decentralized decentralized apps
or adapts for short or even apps that go
beyond the idea of sort of an infinite
application they're more like an
organization and that's the idea of
decentralized autonomous organizations
or Dowd's
right so that's the thing on the far
right on the top and there's just an
explosion of these and what's powering
them is is three things aetherium which
you can view as you know scripts that
are running decentralized processing
that are running that no one owns or
controls and there's a whole stack an
ecosystem around aetherium platforms etc
and then under the hood you know
aetherium hasn't traditionally had much
for storage media so that's where
there's a decentralized file system
that's been emerging that's ipfs
interplanetary file system super cool I
encourage you guys to check it out too
and the database which is actually what
we've been building what I presented
today to you big chain DB this public
versions of all of these to private and
public so with big chain DB will be
actually more fully announcing a public
version of big change EB in a couple
months sorry in a couple weeks but also
in general you can
roll this for private networks or public
networks so we're moving towards a much
more decentralized world sort of an
internet 3.0 and so I'll wrap up
basically big chain DB it's a blockchain
database it's scalable and of course
it's in Python so if you want more
information obviously feel free come
talk to me go to big chain DB comm to
read the docs to get started check out
github and we have a mascot his name is
Wrigley he's a moose he's from
Saskatchewan Canada
like me and that's all I'll wrap up
there thank you very much
Thank You trench thank you for his
stunning presentation questions I would
expect tons of questions we have only
three minutes hello thanks for the
presentation it's an amazing project
something that I seem blockchain and I
don't understand how it works here is
that you mentioned that validation is
through some kind of voting system and I
understand that the nodes are the
entities that vote so what stops me from
spinning up a lot of nodes to get a lot
of votes for example or abusing the
system that way yeah so that actually by
the way is called a Sybil attack and
that's a problem when you have a fully
open network when you have unrestricted
membership so how Bitcoin solves that is
saying you only your you vote is based
on how much electricity you spend how we
do it here actually is with a Federation
where it's a list of public Eve's so
basically if I'm creating a network for
the you know the medical community with
I'll just have the list of the 20
hospitals that I want running nodes and
that's it right and then you can add
nodes and remove nodes in the fly and
basically the adding and removing is the
existing nodes they vote on that when we
roll out the public version of big chain
DB it will also be based on this concept
so we've been actually working on
gathering together a lot of
organizations that really care about the
future of the Internet and the past of
the Internet and collectively they will
form
a bunch of nodes and then to add more
nodes they collectively vote to remove
nodes they vote so it's actually a
pretty good workaround you don't need to
get fancy with crypto economics with
crypto coins or anything like this it's
just a much more pragmatic solution and
it also happens to scale a lot better
but at some point there's this
centralized organization perhaps
democratic that decides who enters and
who doesn't no you don't need it right
you you have these 19 nodes and
basically one entity can propose hey I'm
going I'm going to propose to add this
node here and then all the other nodes
they vote right people can sit down and
decide whether they come in or not right
so you don't need an entity actually a
centralized entity it's just like the
dowel right now right the Dow has it's
this code that's out there running and
you're going to get a vote proportional
to how much money you put in right so if
you put in 10 million dollars you get
less than 10% of a vote it's that nice
anyway
see my question regarding here is I
heard about Bitcoin blockchain but there
will be a validator they call it as -
correct
they will validate each and every
transactions and they will push the
block to the blockchain VP that's
correct yeah that's how Bitcoin works so
basically there's these nodes that they
validate that the blocks are okay and
then in the act of like you you spend
electricity in order to get the chance
to be elected you know randomly based on
how much electricity you spend and if
you get elected if you get chosen in
that round you win the lottery then you
happen to validate that ten minutes
worth and and then that's it that's how
that block gets validated how we work is
we say ignore all that extra complexity
both spending electricity etc and
instead the validation is done by these
existing nodes so there's no mining per
se there's no cryptocurrencies being
created and through that the reward is
extrinsic basically the the participants
in the system that are doing the
validation they have a collective
interest in seeing this network run and
survive
so I have a related question on Undine
incentives if it works but it doesn't
work perfectly and it would benefit from
an upgrade how do you have a tragedy of
the Commons situation or something like
this
you have like two trade offs - 2 volt
who's gonna spend money to run more
notes or stuff like that yeah so in
general with this sort of setup you're
probably gonna have you know 15 25 35
knows you're not gonna have 5000 right
and usually it's going to be a bunch of
people that you probably know like
they're all in your trade organization
or well you know they're all the people
in some supply chain ecosystem etc and
they're going they're all going to be
incentivized to have the most recent
version of the software right if they
don't if it happens to be a speed
optimization maybe they won't bother
upgrading right in the world the block
chains this is called a soft 4 versus a
hard fork so a soft fork means you you
upgrade but it doesn't affect the
protocol at all a hard fork means
everyone really has to upgrade or and
not be going on in the world of
databases you know you think about you
know you've running a database live and
then you have data live on that you do a
migration of the schema right just
schema migrate so this is actually much
healthier way of thinking about it
rather than hard Forks and soft Forks
it's more like okay having scheduled
maintenance upgrades and so on where
everyone agrees and if they don't agree
maybe this it will get stuck in some old
version and that's how it how it works
but overall governance the general
approach to government is basically this
majority idea right whether it's adding
or removing members whether it's
upgrading or not etc right so if you
consistently don't upgrade then you can
get removed as a node and another node
will come in that actually does actually
properly upgrade
yeah great talk train yeah so this leads
me to my question which is majority
votes have you thought about something
else to decide rather than a majority
there's all kinds of ways they can reach
consensus I guess yeah I mean there's a
lot of ideas out there that's actually a
pretty broad design space that you can
have but majority is a pretty good
starting point right there's a lot of
other things even in the world of
traditional blockchains right with
Bitcoin there's this idea of the longest
chain rule so whichever chain of blocks
is the longest that's what the ground
truth is with aetherium there's
something called the ghost Protocol you
can have 2/3 votes you get a majority
vote so you can have things weighted the
majority is actually pretty good it also
ties in nicely with theory from
Byzantine fault tolerance of the to F
plus one 300 plus one so there's there's
other reasons for kind of sticking with
something simple like this for a sort of
theoretical reasons I would like to stop
here thank you very much one more time